so former officer derek chovin was  convicted and he was convicted on  three different counts and i've gotten  so many questions about how can a  criminal defendant be convicted of three  different crimes based on the same  conduct by the defendant guilty here  chovin was convicted of second-degree  murder which in minnesota is the felony  murder statute then you have murder in  the third degree  and finally second degree manslaughter  chauvin will not serve jail related to  all three  the constitution prohibits double  punishment for the same crime  chauvin will only serve time related to  the most serious offense because that's  the one that carries the most jail time  so now you know next time i see you  in court